nettoyage de bureaux pour les
professions libérales et les pros sur
www.nintendo.fr merci d'écouter réunion
la première 12h16 c'est l'heure du lundi
politique et le dantec vous recevez
aujourd'hui olivier hoarau maire du port
est lundi politique
gaël le dantec le rassemblement national
en tête d'un scrutin à la réunion en
tête dans toutes les communes de la
réunion
cette année c'est le paysage politique
inédit que son service pendant les
élections européennes comment un parti
nationaliste d'être un droit peut-il
être en tête d'une élection sur l'île de
la réunion
aucun quartier ne semble épargné par
cette vague pas même la cité portuaire
historiquement ancrée à gauche 30 2% des
électeurs du port ont choisi de voter
pour la liste du rassemblement national
comment va donc le port quelle situation
sociale à quelle colère les politiques
actuelles non pas sur un probant les
initiatives des expériences sont en
cours ou à venir lutte contre l'échec
scolaire lui contre le chômage sont au
programme on en parle avec notre invité
par leur site son avenir politique
lanières de son parti c'est donc olivier
ouart olmert pnr du port est conseiller
régional qui est avec nous faut la
première jusqu'à 13h vos questions au 02
62 99 2000 à partir de 12h45
oliviero bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
le rassemblent des élections en france
s'entête à la réunion quand est-ce que
vous avez réagi vous en découvrant ces
résultats écoutez je pense qu' il ne
faut pas minimiser cette ce résultat
même si et c'est là aussi un
enseignement important dont on parle
assez peu à la réunion c'est le taux
d'abstention qui est de 70%
ici à la réunion ce qui est considérable
ça n'enlève rien aux résultats des
suffrages exprimés mais à la fois la
percée du rassemblement national à la
fois cette abstention encore très
importante
witt encore reculer encore effectivement
au niveau national j'ai vu qu'il ya une
on est sur des bases de 94 mais
justement
malheureusement à la réunion allait
encore trop trop forte
je crois qu'il ya là l'expression d'une
certaine désespérance de la part de la
population
il y a dans ce choix vers le
rassemblement national
aussi la volonté de sanctionner de
sanctionner les partis nationaux de leur
incapacité à répondre aujourd'hui aux
attentes aux urgences parfois d'une
population qui demande et qui attendent
des élus de manière générale une réponse
tout de suite dans l'immédiateté
ce qui n'est manifestement pas chose
possible et c'est aussi le deuxième
enseignement ses attentions à des
discours trop facile des discours
populistes en dix ans et c'est
d'ailleurs la tête de liste
rassemblement national qui le fait je
n'ai pas gagné
il a dit c'est emmanuel macron qui a qui
a déçu et qui a échoué
donc voilà lui même le dit ce n'est pas
mon programme qui a fait gagner mais
c'est celui d' emmanuel macron donc
c'est aussi cette analyse là qu'il faut
avoir dans les résultats
et je tiens à noter que bien sûr
rassemblement national arrive partout en
tête et même au port vous l'avait dit et
je dirais aussi que l'abstention est
très forte il ya que 7000 personnes qui
se sont déplacées mais ça rejoint ce
climat ambiant de manière géniale mais
la participation pour eux étaient
exactement
voilà si on regarde bien aussi dans les
résultats c'est au port ou la gauche
résiste le mieux où l'écart entre
rassemblement national et les forces de
gauche sont un des moins importants
quand on regarde au niveau du territoire
départemental
globalement si si on regarde d'un peu
plus loin qu'on trouvera les relations
il retrouve aussi la tendance au niveau
international la montée des
nationalismes se voit un peu partout est
ce que ces tremblements qui vous
inquiète
vous bien sûr parce que on est sur un
discours populiste et il y a une façon
très simple de répondre à ce qui se
passe au niveau de l'union européenne et
je tiens à rappeler qu'il s'agit d'une
élection européenne et la montée du
nationalisme partout en europe de
manière modérée puisque en espagne ce
n'est pas le cas en allemagne non plus
en france mène c'est plutôt les verts
enregistrent les verts et s'exposent
qu'on y revienne ensuite il y a
manifestement une nécessité aujourd'hui
c'est que tous ces partis nous explique
clairement quelle est leur volonté dans
l'avenir de l'europe
c'est facile de militer au contre
l'europe et de dire votez pour moi est
ce que les gens qui ont voté pour ces
partis nationalistes
c'est un européen à votre avis est-ce
qu'ils ont voté parce qu'ils veulent une
autre europe une ordination comme c'est
parti
la lavande la revendique ou est ce que
c'est un vote contestataire est ce que
vous vous sentez les choses il y à une
crise de confiance manifeste vis-à-vis
des des partis nationaux il y a une
volonté est là aussi de faire évoluer
les choses et moi je pense que
effectivement les institutions
européennes doivent évoluer
je prends l'exemple du président de la
commission européenne
voilà un homme qui a pratiquement tout
pouvoir et qui est désignée haut qui
n'est même pas élu au sein d'un suffrage
ça c'est une évolution qu'il faut
inscrire tout de suite dans l'avenir de
l'union européenne fait rêver mais il
faut qu'il soit confronté au suffrage
universel
peut-être au suffrage universel indirect
à l'image des sénateurs dans notre pays
la deuxième chose il faut absolument que
le parlement est davantage de pouvoir de
contrôle de contre-pouvoir vis-à-vis de
la commission européenne redonner la
place à la population dans le
fonctionnement de ces institutions est
là pour moi un enjeu majeur
si on veut que l'union européenne cette
union batipart schuman
ddd sa création dès le départ soit celle
plutôt des peuples unis vers une europe
sociale une europe à l'écouté de la
population et que ça ne soit pas
uniquement des slogans pour des partis
nationalistes et populistes qui viennent
dire votez pour moi votez pour moi je
suis contre l'europe mais faites-moi
hier au parlement européen là il ya une
ambivalence qu'il faut qu'il faut
clarifier vous dire la participation est
pas très importante même si elle est
plutôt en progression
vous avez rencontrées vous des électeurs
des administrés au port qui vous ont
expliqué soit qu'ils n'allaient pas
voter ou s'ils avaient montré qu'ils
voteraient pour l'heure son vrai nom
très sincèrement non je n'ai pas vu
cette je n'ai pas vu de militants ou
d'habitants me me parler en ces termes
mais ça ne veut pas dire pour autant
qu'il ne faut pas en tenir compte
il y à un appel aussi dans cette
abstention et c'est cela qu'il faut
écouter et comme je voulais dit la
gauche au port puisqu'on parle du port
elle est majoritaire et elle résiste le
mieux
rassemblement national sur tout le
territoire de du département de la
réunion
c'est une relation qui fait quand même
32% chez vous exactement et ce que je
veux dire quand on regarde le score de
la france insoumise quand on regarde le
score de yannick jadot
quand on regarde le score des deux
glucksmann on arrive à près de 40% 42%
donc rien demandé les auditeurs
et un peu les chiffres en tête 1 % pour
la liste mais par amour pour la france
insoumise on a un cadeau à 5 6%
ils sont à 4,6 c'est quand même très
éparpillé après derrière la france où il
est très bas 7
cette élection encore une fois est une
élection nationale sur laquelle au cours
de laquelle nous on a demandé sans avoir
de candidat de voter pour les forces de
gauche et notre appel a été entendu
et si vous avez vous avez pas voulu vous
positionner très clairement mais écoutez
encore une fois voilà une élection où il
ne faut pas faire n'importe quoi et le
résultat il est là je prends pour
exemple les girouettes de la politique
locale qui sont à droite droite qui sont
au centre et qui maintenant sont
emmanuel macron et qui par cette
stratégie perdante uns font le jeu du
rassemblement national et deux ont fait
la démonstration qu'ils n'arrivent plus
à mobiliser
vous pensez à quai à didier robert par
exemple voilà un choix que le
gouvernement a fait qui est perdant leur
le la france pardon le la république en
marche
excusez-moi fait un piètre résultat à
hauteur de 10% pour si ici à la réunion
donc si c'est ça la capacité de main à
construire pour les réunionnais il faut
tout de suite changé mais je crois que
le président de région doit tenir compte
de cet échec et le président de la
république doit tenir compte des auteurs
de cet échec à la réunion alors on
rappellera que didier robert a effectué
soutenu la candidature la liste
sous ce nom il m'a comparé la république
en marche contée par 2e 2e eurodéputés
ne vous dit rien c'est une bonne
nouvelle qui soit 2 où il va non puisque
c'est pas visité scouts et aujourd'hui
on est sur une fois qu'ils sont élus ils
doivent représenter en tant que
réunionnais élu avec les voix
réunionnaise aussi représenter les la
réunion au parlement européen mais pas
seulement mais on a des sujets majeurs
vous savez que la réunion aujourd'hui
est une un territoire en politique
convergence pour pas rentrer dans les
détails mais ça veut dire qu'on
bénéficie de moyens importants de
l'union européenne et que nos deux
députés doivent demain être en phase sur
les sujets majeurs
attention à ne pas se taper dessus
systématiquement au détriment de la
population réunionnaise parce que c'est
là qu'on fera encore le jeu du
rassemblement national
un mot un peu technique oliver vous
aviez écrit au préfet pour l'alerter sur
un certain nombre de dysfonctionnements
sur les listes et orale
on a eu quelques couacs à gérer attendu
bien naturellement ça s'est bien passé
heureusement il n'ya pas eu de problèmes
majeurs on a pu effectivement parer aux
différentes différents problèmes et les
électeurs ont bien compris que d'où
venait le souci et les corrections vont
être mises en place maintenant pour les
prochaines échéances
est ce que je peux vous demander pour
qui vous avez voté le vote est secret
mais au port voilà un score qui est à
gauche
j'ai voté à gauche et j'ai voté j'ai
envie de dire pour celui qui aujourd'hui
pourra défendre les intérêts réunionnais
et portois à la parlement européen et je
voudrais dire donc pour la force en
soirée on ne pas le citer
je voudrais dire aujourd'hui sur votre
question initiale on n'a pas fait
campagne
moi j'ai appelé les électeurs autour de
sujets majeurs qui soit à droite ou à
gauche
on a parlé et c'est ce que je leur ai
soumis comme dossier de continuité
climatique et bien sûr parce que
l'urgence du réchauffement climatique
fait se mobiliser et nous l'avions
intégrer dans nos trois propositions
soumises à tous les candidats
aujourd'hui quand on voit le score des
écologistes sur au niveau national et
même locales et aux ports notamment
montrent que j'avais raison
la deuxième chose on a parlé de
continuité éducative
mais si nous nous battons pour cela
c'est parce que nous croyons que la
méritocratie
elle fonctionne mais à condition que
tout le monde par ce le même la même
ligne de départ on a eu raison parce que
derrière celui qui défend l'idée que
celui qui est déjà en avance c'est lui
qui va gagner et que celui qui est en
difficulté il doit rester à terre
ça c'est notre combat de tous les jours
je suis quelqu'un de gauche j'ai
développé un programme mois des
propositions de gauche tout comme la
dernière proposition qui est la
continuité des politiques publiques
il faut qu'on arrive au niveau local à
nous à avoir des moyens d'adaptation des
décisions nationales
donc vous voyez quand on regarde le
score de l'abstention à la réunion je
l'avais prédit on avait eu raison
quand on regarde le score de la
continuité de l'écologie des écologistes
au niveau national et européen
on avait raison au plr dans les trois
propositions que j'ai que j'ai soumis
donc voyez qu aujourd'hui il n'est plus
question de ce1 de jouer les girouettes
de de s'écharper et de dire c'est un
échec parce que le rassemblement
national etc
nous avons aujourd'hui l'obligation de
nous rassembler quand vous dites quand
vous dites que vous
vous êtes de ceux qui disent encore
aujourd'hui je suis de gauche avec vous
avez dit des thèmes comme l'écologie et
les questions de la politique publique
et politique est ce que est ce que c'est
un discours un positionnement qui tient
encore car encore un écho parmi les
électeurs ou est-ce qu'ils sont plus
attirés par les finalement un nouveau
discours qui consistent à 3 gauche ses
anciens principe aujourd'hui votre
pratique ou progressistes ou
nationalistes qui avaient voulu
interrompre cette élection écoutez le
débat qu'il a voulu à la réunion s'est
traduit par 1 10%
donc c'était une erreur je crois qu'en
politique il faut il faut être
pragmatique
effectivement mais on ne bâtit pas un
programme et l'avenir ceux du
pragmatisme
il faut construire avoir des convictions
il faut qu'on arrive à rassembler autour
de cela mais pour ça il faut faire
preuve à la fois de responsabilité les
gens votent pour des élus responsables
capables d'assumer leur décision
jusqu'au bout oui je suis de gauche
parce que je crois moi au progrès social
je crois moi au collectif je crois moi à
la méritocratie à condition que tout le
monde parle sur le même pied d'égalité
je crois en l'aide sociale de manière
générale et c'est cela qui sort
aujourd'hui et réunionnaises et les
réunionnais des discours populistes
je crois moi aussi dans la capacité des
réunionnaises et des réunionnais à faire
confiance à leurs élus à condition que
l'élu soit responsable la confiance ne
se décrète pas elle se construit et je
suis moi aujourd'hui
soucieux que lorsqu'on voit les scores à
gauche à la réunion de créer ce
rassemblement on a besoin aujourd'hui
que cette gauche soit rassemblée
parce que dispersé alès les disco pop
lancé avancez entre les majorités
comptons beaucoup sur le mont d'or
semblant tout ce qu'on voit pour cette
élection européenne c'est que la gauche
est partie divisée
qu'est-ce qui a pas qu'est-ce qui n'a
pas marché qu'est ce qui marcherait
demain qui qui est le leader qui
pourrait attirer derrière lui tous les
autres
aujourd'hui c'est qu' aujourd'hui la
première force de gauche vous dites
c'est qu'ici les ados c'est c'est
aujourd'hui alors je pense que de
prendre le problème sous cet angle c'est
déjà le condamné est condamné et
l'emmener à l'échec
ce tout jeune et vous savez à la réunion
il ya une intelligente et même en france
et en europe
si on considère d'entre eux dès qu'il ya
un leader et qu'il faut le suivre on est
mauvais en revanche je veux m'inspirer
de ce qui se passe aussi dans les pays
voisins de créer une fédération des
partis de gauche des forces
progressistes
ça c'est possible parce que nous
respectons l'identité de chacun des
partis et de construire et de bâtir les
grandes lignes d'un projet pour la
réunion à gauche qui est dans les
chiffres majoritaire c'est la
démonstration aussi et c'est le résultat
aussi de cette élection européenne
mais pour cela y aller en disant venez
et tout le monde derrière moi c'est déjà
condamné le projet c'est tout le monde
doit travailler ensemble dans le respect
des uns et des autres est ce que ce
travail là il a commencé à ce qu'il ya
des jalons des réunions à ce niveau un
jour les outils sas mais moi je crois
que cette élection européenne nous
oblige aujourd'hui à y aller et moi
j'appelle à ce grand rassemblement des
forces de gauche
j'y crois parce que j'ai confiance en la
france un soumises j'ai confiance dans
le parti mené par glucksmann j'ai
confiance dans le projet écologiste qui
est proposé pour la réunion je veux
prendre juste par exemple chez nous au
port le projet de revalorisation des
eaux en sortie de station d'épuration
pour alimenter des centrales à béton
vous voyez aujourd'hui on alimente des
centrales à béton avec de l'eau potable
quand on sait que préserver notre
ressource en eau est capital pour
l'avenir de nos enfants
donc moi je propose un nouveau projet
écologiste sur mon territoire
donc voilà autant de sujets qui montre
que je ne suis peut-être pas le meilleur
ou le plus grand défenseur de la cause
écologiste mais je peux être bon dans
mon dans mon domaine mais j'appelle à
celles et ceux qui veulent travailler
avec nous sur ce projet par exemple et
de le démultiplier à l'échelle de la
réunion d'y aller ensemble sur
territoire zéro chômeur je crois je suis
persuadé que nous avons une ingénierie
et que je peux la faire partager à
d'autres territoires
voilà aussi des projets communs que nous
pouvons construire ensemble pour rester
encore un peu sur l'appétit que le
policier n'est pas forcément la plus
adaptée mais c'est comme ça que ça
marche
notre système demain il vous faudra pour
leur faire des alliances pour les
prochaines échéances qu'elles soient
municipales ou régionales avec qui vous
avez cité où la force a sollicité les
verts pc r oui oui les entrailles
jusqu'où aujourd'hui je crois que les
militants font les leaders politiques
les militants
les personnes engagées en politique
savent ce qui est bon pour leur avenir
et ce qui n'est pas bon nous ne sommes
pas dans une logique aujourd'hui de
stratégies politiciennes comme vous
l'avez dit je crois plutôt que nous
sommes capables de construire un vrai
projet on a parlé d'écologie mais on
peut parler de l'emploi
on peut parler du développement
économique de manière générique un
moment où il faut se mettre autour du
bien sûr mais bien sûr sur des termes
bien précis que sont le projet et non
pas les personnes vous serez candidat
aux prochaines municipales
je m'attendais un peu à cette question
il forcément savez nous sommes
effectivement moins d'un an de cette
échéance
j'ai un programme j'ai surtout un bilan
est gelée pas porter tout seul je les
portais avec une équipe je les portais
avec des militants
et vous m'accorderez le soin d'en parler
d'abord de le dire à mes militants
on continue ou on s'arrête et bien
entendu vu la qualité de notre bilan et
vu les perspectives que nous ouvrons au
portoise et aux portois
je reviendrai vers vous à l'issue de
cette rencontre avec mes militants
on comprend que vous avez envie plutôt
d'y aller et comment le plr ne peut pas
être présent nous serons présents aux
régionales et encore une fois c'est
huguette bello qui portait écoutez là on
est un peu tôt pour en parler
d'abord je vous laisserai le soin de lui
poser la question mais une évidence
c'est que le plr aujourd'hui a déjà fait
sa démonstration la démonstration de 2,2
parti rassembleur jeu j'en appelle
encore une fois à notre capacité à notre
intelligence collective de leaders de
partis à travailler ensemble et non pas
contre chacun l'un contre l'autre
vous faites partie d'une génération va
dire de jeunes engagés en politique je
n'ai lu à la réunion est-ce que qu'est
ce qu'il ya de nouveau aujourd'hui
conclut ce concept on va parler avec eux
avec les résultats que l'on connaît
qu'est ce que commence on fait la
politique est un peu différemment
aujourd'hui
par rapport à vos aînés combattre au
corps ce qu'on essaie de convaincre
finalement tous ceux qui se sont
éloignés des urnes ce qu'ils sont
méfiants vis à vis la politique en ce
qu'on fait pour le trottoir je crois que
il ya un élément important quand on est
acteur politique et donc public c'est la
responsabilité
un homme politique qui a des des
missions confiées par les militants par
les camarades c'est d'abord un homme qui
doit faire preuve de responsabilité
parce qu'il a la confiance de celles et
ceux qui lui ont accordé leurs suffrages
et donc c'est un homme qui doit faire
preuve aussi d'une capacité de
rassemblement sur un territoire comme le
port vous avez cité le parti communiste
réunionnais qui a fait beaucoup de
choses et quand on analyse les résultats
à la réunion de manière générale et
quand on analyse le résultat on voit
qu'aujourd'hui les militants communistes
ont tout intérêt à se remettre en
question et encore une fois nous on a
fait la démonstration pendant notre
mandat qu'on n'est pas dans une guerre
contre les camarades les ego il faut les
mettre de côté maintenant
mais non il faut qu'on travaille
ensemble pour les portoises les portois
en ce qui me concerne les peaux la
réunion de manière générale et nous
sommes capables je le sais j'en suis
persuadé de le faire aux livres ou
est-ce que selon vous le mouvement et
gilet jaune a fait bouger le jeu
politique qui est ce qu'il faut du coup
ça aussi un peu évolué la démocratie m
de notre assise participative de la
démocratie directe c'est que les
chansons force de cauter alors là le
mouvement des jets les jeunes évidemment
à marquer cette élection européenne
la porte est encore une fois des
discours populistes et les résultats
qu'on a qu'on analyse ce matin quand on
parle pouvoir d'achat quand on voit
quand on parle effectivement moyens
d'agir tout de suite sur les
institutions vous parliez de nouveaux
nouvelle méthode de démocratie moi j'y
crois
mais attention aussi à ne pas tomber
dans la facilité les discours facile et
trop facile savez quand on parle de
responsabilité il faut être capable
d'aller jusqu'au bout il faut être
capable d'assumer ses décisions ses
choix il faut pas systématiquement
retourné sa veste en disant c'est à
cause d'eux
autres c'est à cause de nous si nous
avons des résultats que nous avons
défendues moi je suis à l'aise sur ces
élections là et je les entends 7 ccc
portoise c'est pour toi c'est
réunionnaises et réunionnais qui ont
fait un choix de la facilité parce
qu'ils disent avec avec le rassemblement
national
enfin on va passer à autre chose mais il
était niveau identique en en 2000 en
2014 sur 15 12 ont été mis en examen
député européen donc vous voyez je crois
que la responsabilité c'est aussi faire
preuve d' écoute de présence et c'est de
ça que la population a besoin
ils ne veulent plus d'élus arrogant un
but de la personne ils ont besoin d'élus
disponibles et de proximité sur la
démocratie participative ou démocratie
directe vous êtes les régionales il le
conseil a mis en place un conseil
consultatif citoyen avec des dissidents
est une bonne solution
nous allons voir les résultats mais
aujourd'hui ce cette méthode ne peinent
à démarrer
même si il ces nouveaux j'en conviens
laissant du le soin de s'exprimer
je vais voir les résultats je crois que
les électeurs aujourd'hui plutôt que de
dire donnez nous les moyens d'agir
ils ont besoin de retour sur les
questions qu'ils ont posées
c'est pour ça que je parle de proximité
ils ont besoin d'élus disponible qui ne
soit pas là uniquement en campagne
électorale ils ont besoin d'élus qui se
sent ça s'organise qu'est ce que vous
mettez en place vous au port pour
organiser la première des choses c'est
d'être humble je ne suis pas supérieur
je suis l'égal de tous même si j'ai des
responsabilités importantes c'est ça la
proximité avec les électeurs et donc
aujourd'hui le fait de s'isoler demande
fait dire aux électeurs
on va tout changer parce que quand je
veux voir mon maire quand je vais voir
le président de région j'y arrive pas et
donc je veux moi aussi intervenir à un
moment donné dans le débat il faut faire
attention
aussi à la réponse qu'on doit apporter à
l'électorat d'abord faire preuve de
responsabilité je le dis à nouveau faire
preuve aussi de capacité de rassembler
mais tout cela avec une démarche de
construction d'une confiance avec
l'électorat
vous avez rencontré le président en
février
vous lui avez parlé ce que vous avez eu
fait partie des élus qui la parole
devant le crédit que vous les avez parlé
de du projet territoire c'est son choix
sur le port mais aussi pourquoi pas vous
avez dit à l'époque pourquoi pas à
l'étranger l'ensemble la réunion il
s'agit alors le territoire 0 chemin est
un dispositif expérimental sur dix
territoires aujourd'hui identifiés au
niveau national qui consiste à
identifier les chômeurs de longue durée
et de leur apporter de les faire
recruter par une entreprise de bons
emplois et derrière ça bute d'emploi
pardon et de les recruter en cdi
aujourd'hui perçoivent le rsa pour
arriver au smic
il manque une différence d'à peu près
600 700 euros l'état apporterait ses
moyens uniquement pour les chômeurs de
longue durée et ces personnes
travailleraient sur des activités non
marchandes dead d'accompagnement sur le
territoire et je sais qu'il ya autre
chose parce qu'il faut pas que ce soit
parce qu'il ya une vraie demande auprès
des personnes âgées notamment les
personnes en situation de handicap il ya
donc où des personnes vraiment en
situation d'exclusion
donc il ya un vrai marché donc le
nouveau port on a candidaté c'est sûr
appel à projets aujourd'hui et le
président de la république l'a dit
devant toute la france
ça ne vous a pas échappé monsieur le
maire du port vous êtes candidat
allons-y nous sommes prêts à vous suivre
il ya une étape effectivement
législatives à avoir je crois que avant
la fin de l'année il y aura une loi qui
va passer qui sera présenté dans ce sens
où de nouveaux territoires vont est
identifié et j'ai bon espoir parce que
notre dossier est bon que le port soit
retenue dans ce nouveau
textes législatifs mais ça nous oblige
aussi à réfléchir tout de suite à cette
à la capacité d'extension sur tout le
territoire
si on est capable de le faire pour le
port on peut le faire ailleurs et donc
je voudrais là aussi appelé celles et
ceux qui sont confrontés dans leur
commune ou autres les associations par
exemple à venir nous nous rejoindre pour
travailler sur un projet plus global à
l'échelle de notre département dans
cette rencontre avec le président de la
république vous aviez également expliqué
que les mesures les réformes entreprises
par le par le gouvernement vous amener à
penser que le gouvernement au président
et vous ne regardiez pas dans la même
direction
est ce que vous dites toujours la même
chose est ce que vous considérez que la
politique menée par le coup leur devoir
nous vraiment bon sens et et que vous
devriez à dire aujourd'hui si vous
rencontrez de nouveau
je crois que les résultats de des
élections européennes à la réunion du
mouvement représenté par nathalie
oiseaux montre qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui je crains que le
gouvernement n'ait pas d'ambition pour
la réunion et il faut absolument changer
de logiciel
concernant la réunion le gouvernement
doit changer de logiciel
il a tardé à mettre territoire zéro
chômeur il est obligé de le faire
aujourd'hui parce que ce sont des
réponses concrètes qu'on peut apporter
sur notre territoire sur le
développement économique sur le
développement social
nous ne pouvons plus considérer que le
territoire de la réunion soit traitée
d'égal à égal avec d'autres territoires
compte tenu des difficultés croissantes
qu'enregistre notre notre département
je prends par exemple le nombre
croissant de bénéficiaires du rsa
je prends par exemple l'éloignement qui
augmente notre
prix d'arrivée le prix de vente sur nos
territoires donc il faut absolument
bâtir avec les réunionnais un nouveau
projet avec les réunionnais mais qu'ils
se trompent pas d'acteur parce que là
encore une fois il s'est trompé et il se
prend une bonne veste comme on dit sur
cette élection européenne
à la réunion on m'a mis au standard qui
souhaite vous poser une question en
s'écoutant ya bonjour et moi mais parce
que justement à ça casse passée ces
élections là on a oublié vraiment aussi
le lan patriotique il ya beaucoup
elle a beaucoup l état des lieux puis
l'équipage du patriotisme
les ja happ toujours quand même la
violence et tout ça on est divisés par
tous ces partis politiques
et puis justement moi je pense qu'une
alliance où je pouvais vous réfléchissez
comme vous dites bien généreux n'est
jamais réunion en tant que ça la
pression du match on a tous la bougie et
enfin les gens qui n'ont revenons pas
les moyens mais un petit moyen quand
même c'était quand même d'avoir un
mouvement constructif
allez constructivement et ça y est
vraiment constructivement pour la
réunion pour l'europe et c'est à quoi
auront paul d'une montée de
nationalistes et je sais pas monter
comme ça et qu'il ya quelque chose qui
dans le 100 m qui est du bon quand on
vous dit qu'il contaminait donc faut
nettoyer mois voilà ont déjà politique
quoi quels que soient les mots merci
merci à venir pour montrer les choses
remarque olivier waro qui qui nous
répond qu'est-ce que onze français
ce besoin qui aurait d'une réponse
des arbres qui est trop longtemps et
économiques et politiques exactement
et vous avez entendu dans les propos
d'amir il a parlé de nécessité de se
rassembler nécessité de construire
ensemble nécessité aussi de dire ce qui
n'est pas bon et d'arrêter ce qui n'est
pas bon de faire le bilan des avancées
des échecs nous sommes moi mes militants
mes camarades m'ont partie de ceux qui
disent la réunion un grand projet pour
la france et traiter la réunion
uniquement sur la base et de
l'interpeller uniquement au moment des
élections n'est pas la bonne solution et
nous réunionnais nous l'a déjà démontré
notre capacité à construire ensemble à
aller ensemble à dire à nous protéger
aussi des risques majeurs liés au
changement climatique
quelle est aujourd'hui la vision de la
réunion sur cette question je prends un
autre exemple aujourd'hui on a la
réunion est confronté à la gestion des
déchets vous voyez aujourd'hui on en est
à faire demi-tour à faire machine
arrière à inventer un autre projet on
perd du temps et de l'argent
vous croyez qu'avec le peu d'argent que
les créoles nana 2 en 1 pour mener nous
les encore le temps d'aller période et
gaspiller notre argent qu'ils les
l'histoire de votre position au-delà de
ces personnes je crois que faire deux
pas en avant trois en arrière nous mène
droit directement droit dans le
nationalisme et le populisme c'est parce
que diamir amiens nous dit mais allons
s'entendre sur l'avenir de la réunion
oui les facile de dire miam la réunion
même la réunion et puis après on voit
plus personne
moi je les dis un élu c'est celui qui
est responsable qui reste et qui assume
ses décisions et qui a une vision pour
la réunion donc moi je je crois en cela
et je remercie amiens pensons son
intervention sur sur la gestion des
déchets puisque vous attendu ces
personnes vous soyez plutôt pour quelles
options sûres
oui quand on a un projet qui est bien
avancé que c'est pas lui vae et qu'on a
des acteurs et qu'il ya une mobilisation
autour de ce projet d analyse d
expertise qui sont concluantes et qu'on
essaie d'arriver avec un autre projet
juste pour montrer qu'on on a une
un plan b bon moi vous savez je crains
que ce débat ne se limite à ça et
pourtant les enjeux sont capitaux il
faut qu'on arrête de dire à la réunion
on a toujours un plan b
parce que c'est celui là qui nous fait
perdre du temps et de l'argent
on a le comprend bien que les gens se
tournent vers finalement peut-être ceux
qui n'ont pas encore été vous pouvoir en
votant pour leur assemblée nationale par
exemple est-ce que vous en tant qu'élu
entre son sein politique vous pouvez
aujourd'hui dire aux électeurs aux
citoyens à vos administrés oui on a des
possibilités on a des solutions pour que
ça aille mieux pour vous parce que
pourquoi est-ce qui vous croire et
maintenant ils ont cru dans les allées
des années puis ça n'avance pas le choix
j'ai toujours aussi fort la mise à jour
la pauvreté jours-ci ontario pourquoi
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous ferez
confiance parce que nous sommes encore
une fois en capacité de dire ce qui n'a
pas marché et d'arrêter ce qui n'a pas
marché et de ne pas poursuivre sur des
stratégies où il faut changer
systématiquement de veste parce que nous
au port on a été élu sur un projet on a
été élu sur une capacité à être en
réaction
parfois en réactivité aussi en tout cas
dans la proximité avec nos électeurs
nous avons eu un projet où on a porté un
projet en disant moi
olivier waro mon équipe plr au sein de
la majorité municipale
nous allons pouvoir mettre en place des
dispositifs des dalles emplois et de
création d'emplois on a tous portent
leurs fruits qui marche mais écoutez on
est la deuxième commune de la réunion
qui a créé le plus de
ploie avec des projets qui ont été
initiées avant mais je ne revendique pas
la paternité des projets encore une fois
je dis simplement que ma capacité était
de mener à bien un projet d'envergure
régionale
je dis encore une fois que si je me bat
aujourd'hui pour la création d'un lycée
des métiers de la mer
ça n'est pas pour faire parler de moi
c'est parce que les métiers des les
métiers de la mer sont aujourd'hui
porteur nous allons accueillir très
bientôt
un chantier naval au port mais côté il
faut préparer les marmailles dès
maintenant on a besoin de soudeur on a
besoin d'eux d'électricien spécifique il
faut les mettre en formation dès
maintenant n'attendons pas donc j'ai
fait la démonstration que nous pouvons
apporter autre chose à la réunion et
donc oui il ya encore une capacité d
écoute d'entente sans tomber dans les
extrêmes est plutôt de rassembler le
plus large possible et de dire poids la
réunion demain nous sommes une terre est
un atout considérable pour la france
notamment dans l'océan indien sur les
métiers de la mer gelée dit mais aussi
sur des activités économiques
extraordinaires que parce que nous avons
une intelligence nous des jeunes qui
sont formés à la réunion ou ailleurs et
qui peuvent demain exporter leur savoir
faire à propos de formation l'éducation
la ville du port est la seule ville à la
région choisie par le gouvernement pour
être éligible au programme cité
éducative de quoi s'agit-il
alors c'est un projet qui est enfin une
démarche nationale qui identifie les
communes qui ont un bon projet
pédagogique sur son territoire il se
trouve que notre projet a été retenu il
est meilleur que celui des autres en
tant mieux je n'en tiens pas une gloire
particulière je dis ça il y a une
capacité encore une fois chez nous à
travailler en bonne intelligence avec
tous les partenaires caf conseil
départemental et c est ça va nous
apporter des moyens en terme
d'organisation de
de nos moyens déjà existants mais je le
dis et vous faites très bien de poser
cette question si c'est simplement pour
se faire remarquer ça m'intéresse pas à
nous on a un projet qui avance qui
fonctionne on a un projet éducatif qui
est aujourd'hui est très ambitieux pour
nos jeunes dans les écoles afin en terme
de fonctionnement de moyen d'ouverture
pédagogique d'accès à la culture au
sport et ce projet là nous n'avons pas
attendu site éducative pour le porter et
le faire aboutir
six sites et ducati nous apporte des
moyens supplémentaires allant je suis
preneur il nous reste une petite minute
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur peut-être
ce qui a été le coeur de cette émission
de vote pour le rassemblement national
il ya une dimension qui est important
dans son mottaki et durs sont contre
l'immigration si tu as un rejet des
immigrés des étrangers comment est-ce
que vous analysez vous ce vote cette
question je crois que la question des
immigrés des étrangers est toujours
prise du mauvais côté par certains
décideurs politiques et il ya quelques
années dans les années 90 le
gouvernement en place a sorti une loi en
disant on interdit le voile dans les
espaces publics etc
c'est de là que c'est parti ministre de
l'intérieur nicolas sarkozy c'est de là
que tous les problèmes
ensuite on se sont aggravées et c'est
cet acte là qui a donné au rassemblement
national les moules et les motifs
d'aller encore plus loin et donc moi je
dis que ce problème est mal perçu et jeu
ça me fait mal aujourd'hui à la réunion
au port de voir des jeunes qui disent
mais moi je suis de confession musulmane
chrétienne ou autre mais oui parce que
et et qui me disent j'ai du mal à venir
à l'école etc etc je suis tout en bloc
et je crois que l'espace public
l'appropriation de l'espace public doit
être plus présente et et mieux
appréhender par nos décideurs publics et
politiques
et moi je défends encore une fois notre
capacité à accueillir
étrangers parce que c'est une source de
richesse pour nous à condition que ce
soit bien organisé et ses 2 le refus de
s'organiser qui crée chez les autres des
peurs merci beaucoup aux libéraux
d'avoir été avec nous dans l'indie
politique dans deux minutes saisonnière
qui va évidemment comme tous les jours
sa musique passer une journée sur la
première
[Musique]
à
m
c'est court
12h15 à 13h le club de la presse sur la
première on va parler des élections
européennes qu'il faut d'accord
chauriens choc qu'une chose qui compte
maintenant il y avait une vraie
tentative de conjonction entre 0 berre
et dès qu'on soit pour ou contre moi je
vous dis je suis ni pour ni contre le
club de la presse tous les mardis de
12h15 à 13h avec gail le dantec sur la
première attention et